les longères de la cafrine
à partir de 1848 les engagés
travailleurs libres sous contrat
remplace les esclaves ils vivent peut
aussi dans des camps situés à proximité
des sucreries
regroupant une population parfois
importantes ces camps sont de grand
village où se mêlent paillote maison en
bois est long bâtiment rectangulaire en
pierre ces derniers appelés longirod
calbanons font leur apparition dans les
années 1860 sur les grandes propriétés
sucrières
un seul bâtiment étant plus économique
que plusieurs petites maisons les
longères sont de grandes constructions
tout en longueur divisé en plusieurs
logements chaque famille d'engager
dispose d'une pièce unique dans laquelle
règne une grande promiscuité
progressivement d affecter à partir des
années 1970 elles seront peu à peu
laissée à l'abandon ou démolis vite
tomber en ruine après le départ de leurs
derniers habitants en 1991 les longères
de la cafrine ont été rénovés à
l'initiative des descendants d'engager
de cette ancienne propriété sucrière
l'exposition installée dans l'une des
quatre longs j'ai réhabilité permet de
découvrir l'histoire du quartier mais
aussi de pénétrer dans ces logements de
10 mètres carrés dans les seules
ouvertures se réduisent à une porte
d'entrée parfois une petite fenêtre
construit en pierre à chaux et à sable
ses quatre bâtiments de cinq mètres 30
de large sur 33 de long pour les plus
importants sont des témoins essentiels
de l'habitat populaire réunionnais